rarely a day is going by certainly not a
week where we don't learn
yet another element
of the absurdity and insanity and in
some cases the criminality that
allegedly took place during the trump
administration you have been following
the story if you've been watching the
show listening to the show of donald
trump taking classified documents to
mar-a-lago flushing documents
incinerating documents no word yet on
whether he smoked or sauteed any but
that would be the next shoe to drop
the national archives have now confirmed
and turned over to the justice
department that donald trump did take
classified items to his house at
mar-a-lago and the projection all along
has just been stunning
remember
hillary clinton can't be trusted her
emails
private email
she would be irresponsible with
sensitive and classified documents well
then trump during his presidency goes
and spills secrets to a russian spy
recruiter sergey kislyak in the oval
office
trump's family like ivanka and jared
kushner and others using private email
for white house business
trump ripping up presidential records
which people come in and tape back
together
trump sending documents in burn bags to
the pentagon to be incinerated which are
to be kept by the presidential records
act according to the presidential
records act trump flushing documents
down the toilet clogging it having to
call maintenance to unclog the toilet
and yes
he took classified documents to his
house
national archives ap report trump took
classified items to mar-a-lago
classified information
was found in the 15 boxes of white house
records that were stored at former
president donald trump's mar-a-lago
residents the national archives
said friday in a letter that confirms
the matter has been sent to the justice
department that's called possible
criminality
the letter from the agency follows
numerous reports around trump's handling
of sensitive and even classified
information during his time as president
and after he left the white house the
revelation could also interest federal
investigators for policing the handling
of government secrets though the justice
department and fbi have not indicated
they will pursue
federal law bars the removal of
classified documents to unauthorized
locations though it is possible that
trump could try to argue that as
president he was the ultimate
declassification authority
so there's a couple different things
here and some of you have written to me
and said david the classified nature
doesn't matter only the violations of
the presidential records act matter
because trump as the president can
declassify anything that's up for legal
dispute
uh spoke to a couple lawyers who said
so yes trump can declassify anything
that he wants
however he didn't declassify these
things he just took them and there is
this
weird
in-between situation where there's the
violation of the presidential records
act
there is an issue with him taking
classified documents although he could
declassify them but merely taking them
doesn't by definition declassify them
it's a legal matter to sort out
but looking backwards everything trump
talked about others doing
he was doing he said hillary will do all
of this stuff no no no you will do it
and you did do it remember the toilet
ran we all sought
why is trump talking about toilets over
and over and over again he's
obsessed with the fact that toilets
aren't flushing like they used to
and now maybe we know remember this we
have a
situation where we're looking very
strongly at sinks and showers
and other elements of bathrooms
where
you turn the faucet on in areas where
there's tremendous amounts of water
where water rushes out to sea because
you could never handle it
and you don't get any water you turn on
the faucet you don't get any water
they
take a shower and water comes dripping
out it's dripping out very
quietly dripping out
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times
as opposed to once
they end up using more water right
trump's complaints about good old
toilets just aren't flushing the way
they used to
for all we know it was because he was
trying to flush documents down the
toilet
and it was getting clogged
and he was having to call maintenance so
this is this is all as bad as anything
he said anybody else was doing
um consider also how in the meantime fox
news has barely barely covered this
story
but they did mention hillary clinton
like a hundred times over the weekend on
the basis of the supposed durham report
we're gonna get to that in a moment so
at the end of the day
trump could have declassified these
documents so that he would not have been
stealing classified documents as the
president he does have the ultimate
authority to declassify there is this
kind of weird in-between status he
definitely violated the presidential
records act that we know
and no one would believe this if it
weren't all completely true it's too
absurd if you wrote a screenplay about a
wacky president and you included a scene
of him flushing documents down the
toilet after accusing his opponent of
being untrustworthy with documents
it would be like you can't do it it's
too it's too much it's too cliche it's
too absurd no one would believe it no
one would do it it is real life folks
it's real real life and that's what's
going on
i want to introduce you to emmy the
world's first instant ramen that is low
carb high protein and 100
plant based
each serving of imi is packed with 21
grams of protein
19 grams of fiber has only five net
carbs works for keto diets and 35
percent less sodium than traditional
ramen brands i've been making it at home
just like any instant ramen it's ready
in just a few minutes you can use the
microwave you can use the stovetop you
really can't beat the convenience but
with imi you can feel good about the
ramen you're eating because of all the
fiber the lower sodium and it is
plant-based which i love even though i'm
not vegan or vegetarian but the best
part is
it's so well packaged it comes in
flavors like spicy beef
tom yum shrimp
black garlic chicken the taste and the
quality of the ingredients really sets
it apart from any other instant ramen
i've had and emmy is giving my audience
five dollars off a variety pack when you
go to emmyeats.com
pacman and use the coupon code pacman
the link is down below